liberal supreme court justice stephen
breyer the oldest member of the court
has signaled that he will soon retire
and the search for breyer's replacement
should move relatively quickly the
reason for that is that president biden
has already taken 94 percent of the
country out of the running
joe biden has decided that his next
supreme court nominee will be a black
woman
forget about qualifications forget about
talent forget about experience
joe is going to pick his judicial
nominee just like he chose his vice
president
he's going to choose her on sex
and skin color first
maybe you consider the person
second
no one wants a new liberal judge on the
court of course
but this is actually relatively good
news a liberal replacing a liberal does
not change the balance of the court
briar was going to go away sooner or
later
and the decision to step down now
almost certainly means one thing
justice breyer thinks that the democrats
are headed for disaster in the november
midterm elections i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from we are helmuth
hubiner
who says
my friend got kovid pretty badly he
wasn't able to breathe so he went to the
emergency room they wouldn't let him in
because he's unvaccinated they told him
to quote go home and drink some water
i've heard many such cases i have heard
cases of people going trying to get
medical treatment and the the people at
the medical tree whether it's an
emergency room or whether it's urgent
care whether it's your regular doctor
will force you to take a covid test and
then if you have covid you're not
allowed to come in
only healthy people are allowed to go to
the doctor if you're a sick person
you're not allowed to go to the doctor
does that make sense no it seems kind of
upside down
now one way to remedy this upside down
world we're living in is to get upside
you are paying too much for gas i
promise you that because gas is going
through the roof and there's no end in
sight well i
have a wonderful gift for you
you can save
25 cents every time at 25 cents per
gallon every time you fill up you will
get it cash back using get upside
get upside is this free app and when you
use promo code knowles
you actually will not just get 25 cents
per gallon cashback you will get 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank
people who drive a lot are saving as
much as two to three hundred bucks per
year could you use two to three hundred
bucks per year i sure could
go download the free get upside app
right now there is no reason not to do
it there's no catch only cash back goes
straight to your bank account or to
paypal or to an amazon gift card if you
prefer very simple download the free get
upside app use promo code knowles get up
to 50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank that is code k w l e s knolls
joe biden's got another diversity hire
coming up
it's as simple as that
he did the same thing with his vice
presidential selection
for kamala harris and now he's going to
do it with his judge kamala harris got
her job
not because she is qualified not because
she is intelligent not because she is
educated
i don't think she has any of those
things but even if she were that
wouldn't be why she got the job she got
her job because she is black and because
she's a woman
you don't need to take my word for it
that's what joe biden said this next
judicial nominee for the supreme court
will get her job won't be him it'll be
her job
because she is black and because she is
a woman
her qualifications her experience will
have very little to do with it the
democrats now are leaking some of the
potential nominees
and they're they're leaking them not not
in a list of qualifications or resume or
accomplishment it's just like looking at
a a bunch of paint swatches they're just
doing it on race
and sex
clarence thomas reacted against this
when clarence thomas the
senior most conservative judge on the
court
when he was when he was graduating from
law school this was after
affirmative action came about and he
graduated from law school
very
serious law student he's become one of
the most accomplished jurists in the
country
and he had trouble getting a job and he
realized he had trouble getting a job
even though he graduated from the top
law school in the country even though he
had this great resume he had trouble
getting a job because people didn't
think that he got to where he was
on him on the merits people assumed that
he got to where he was on the color of
his skin because of affirmative action
and he said it was at that point that he
saw that the value of his yale law
degree was was basically nothing
it was at that point he felt the sting
of
racism
associated with affirmative action and
that's what's going to happen to this
supreme court nominee it doesn't matter
how qualified this person is or how
unqualified this person is
they will always that she will always be
a diversity hire
kamala harris will always be a diversity
hire
it's sad
that's sad you know i don't think
that's how we want these things to
happen
clarence thomas was not a diversity hire
by the way
george h.w bush didn't say i will pick
uh i will pick a black man of this
i'm not saying that race didn't factor
into his calculation
but actually the promise that came from
george h.w bush and his staff was we're
going to pick a true conservative he he
prioritized thomas's ideas his judicial
philosophy over any of his physical
characteristics
not so
here and that's sad is if you were to be
the first black woman supreme court
justice wouldn't you want to be picked
based on your talent and your
intelligence and your
career
i think so but the left doesn't really
care the left just wants the power and
they'll take it any way that they can
get it
gensake is getting peppered with
questions about this and gensake's
double down yes this regardless of
qualifications this will be a black
woman on the court
does president biden plan to honor his
pledge to nominate a black woman to the
court well i've commented on this
previously the president has
stated and reiterated his commitment to
nominating a black woman to the supreme
court and certainly
stands by that
for today again i'm just not going to
be able to say anything about
any specifics until of course justice
breyer makes any announcement should he
decide to make an announcement
now speaking of kamala harris and the
last time this came around some people
are suggesting kamala harris could be
the nominee
because joe biden's got this political
problem right now namely uh
harris and biden appear to hate one
another
harris is extremely unpopular she may
actually drag down the ticket joe biden
is the most unpopular
the least popular president in recent
history and somehow his vice president
is even less popular so what do you do
with kamala well you could throw her on
the court and then you don't have to
deal with her anymore and then you take
her off the table as a potential rival
and as a potential drag on your ticket
it would be a travesty
for the country because kamala harris is
not particularly smart not particularly
well educated and and doesn't have a lot
of integrity
but it might solve a political problem
for biden it's it's
it's not ironic
it's providential you might say
that we are seeing the affirmative
action supreme court nomination
occurring right as the court is
reconsidering affirmative action
there's a major affirmative action case
we talked about a couple days ago coming
up before the court
affirmative action is unconstitutional
even the judges who upheld affirmative
action acknowledged that it was
unconstitutional about 20 years ago the
last time there was a major affirmative
action case where the court upheld it
sandra day o'connor who was the swing
vote there a conservative appointee who
then became the swing vote and sided
with the liberals she said obviously
affirmative action is unconstitutional
it's wrong the text of the 14th
amendment plainly prevents this sort of
discrimination and subsequent laws that
came after the 14th amendment this kind
of discrimination on the basis of race
but we're going to let it stay for a
little while but obviously it's limited
in time and in about 25 years we've got
to get rid of it well here we are now
and whoever gets picked for this this
court seat might might very well be the
last dying gasp of affirmative action we
can only
hope
why why is is joe biden so desperate to
fill this court seat now why why is
justice breyer so desperate to get off
the court now yeah he's a little bit
long in the tooth sure but i think what
it signals is that the democrats know
they're headed for disaster in the
midterm elections they're predicted
overwhelmingly to lose the house of
representatives right now and they may
well lose the senate if they lose the
senate then cocaine mitch is going to
come in and he is going to show you his
little friend and he is going to stop
any supreme court nomination because it
needs the approval of the senate and so
as it stands right now they've got six
seven months
to get this nomination through
and so they're going to do the best they
can
right now looking ahead not just to 2022
but to 2024 joe biden is losing
to a generic republican he's losing
pretty significantly to the generic
republican who goes up on the ballot
against him but there's a caveat here
this is according to a politico morning
consult poll
when you put biden up against
some republican
biden gets crushed
when you put biden up against any actual
republicans
biden wins
so by if biden goes up against trump
according to
this poll
4544 biden wins biden goes up against
cruz number two guy last time
45-39
biden wins
if biden goes up against pence
44-42 biden wins even desantis who is
the the darling right now
44 39
biden wins
what does this mean what are we supposed
to make of this first thing we're
supposed to make of this is there's no
such thing as a generic republican or a
generic democrat
this is you always hear this from people
who don't pay a lot of attention to
politics and who are a little bit
squishy they'll say oh if we could just
have a normal candidate
oh if we could just have a kind of
normal regular candidate
oh biden would get crushed
but the problem is there's trump there's
cruz there's desantis there's pence
pence is about as generic as they come
there's
whoever hawley haley
christie gnome
oh the problem is just these particular
people there's no there's no generic
person
everyone has a personality okay
and i also don't believe the poll i
don't believe this poll for one second i
think that right now what the democrats
are doing is they're trying to push
certain polls onto the public to suggest
that
the leading republican candidates can't
win
better get rid of all your top
candidates republicans go just pick some
squish guy that no one's ever heard of
go pick romney 3.0
i don't think so i don't really buy that
but my takeaway from this poll is
actually the opposite that the dems want
us to take away if there's no such thing
as a generic republican that's fine give
me an eccentric republican give me a
republican with personality give me a
republican with a backbone
biden is weak
let's go for it let's go all the way
why why are people shift even if they
don't like the republican candidates
even if the poll is right about that why
are people shifting into the republican
camp
i don't think it's because they're
reading
very obscure political philosophy and
they're engaged in all the very online
debates between the various factions of
the right and there they've gone back to
read the enlightenment philosophers and
aristotle no do you know what i think it
is
i think they're looking at
the southern border and they're
realizing that we don't have a border
that we don't have a country anymore
because millions of people are pouring
across
i think they're looking at their streets
especially if they're living in a major
city
and they're watching people go around
and rob and steal and rape kill pillage
and burn and they're saying well this is
bad
stop doing this this is bad policy give
me the other guy
sometimes conservatives we get a little
bit too much in our own heads and we say
well this is because of this philosophy
and because they've someone read this
think piece that appeared in this
magazine no it comes down to pretty
basic stuff the big issues where
republicans stand to make huge gains
what are they
education immigration crime
education immigration crime this is the
area where the the difference between
public opinion and elite opinion
certainly in the democratic party but in
a lot of republican circles too is huge
huge chasm here
americans want normal education kick out
the creepy racial and sexual stuff they
want an actual border and much less
immigration both illegal and legal
immigration drastically reduced and they
want to lock up criminals
basics this is the basic stuff that a
society does
and the elites mostly in the democratic
party but in the republican party too
have forgotten a lot about that there is
a comedian michael rappaport very
emotional very left-wing comedian very
outspoken democrat comedian
he just took a video
he was in a drug store in new york and
he sees a guy some criminal walk in fill
up a bag full of stuff in a drug store
and just walk right out without paying
yo
i'm looking at this [ __ ] this dude
this [ __ ] yo dad this dude is
i can't believe
i'm seeing this [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
yo
this [ __ ] guy just filled his two bags
up
with everything
in rite aid right here on 80th and first
avenue is walking down the street like
[ __ ] is gucci look at me in my face like
what's
good he's i was watching him the whole
time
my man just went christmas shopping in
january
he got the condoms
the shampoo
but that's not possible michael
rappaport because aoc told me this isn't
really happening there's been a spate of
drugstore robberies going on coast to
coast sea to shining sea
cvs walgreens duane reed all these
places are closing stores and they're
closing stores because
people are robbing them blind there are
other reasons as well but that's a big
part of it
talking millions and millions of dollars
worth of stuff
and the left led by aoc says one this
isn't happening and if you say it's
happening you're a racist why i don't
know you are
and two
the reason it is happening is because
people need to feed their families
they always this is like when dr fauci
said there there is no gain of function
research we're not funding gain of
function and all the gain of function
with funding is fine
which is it you're speaking out of both
sides of your mouth you're contradicting
yourself that's what aoc is doing here
there is no
robbery epidemic in drug stores and also
it's great that they're stealing stuff
they need to feed their families well
michael rappaport says here uh he ain't
stealing a loaf of bread
this guy was stealing boxes of condoms
okay you don't need that to feed you you
need that to stop from having a family
you need that to prevent your family
from growing
if you're not going to remain abstinent
but you certainly don't need you don't
need that to feed your family
so this guy goes in steals a bunch of
stuff he's probably gonna go sell it on
the street
and take the money
daily wire reported that
cvs just cvs alone has announced it will
close about 900 retail locations over
the next three years that's about nine
percent of its ten thousand stores
this is at least partially attributed to
the increased theft
and michael rappaport he's so confused
the democrats they're so confused
why
how is this happening in new york city
criminals are being allowed to go into
shops and commit crimes and then just
walk away and not be arrested or
prosecuted
oh we need to get some investigators how
did this happen could it could it have
something to do with the fact that
democrat prosecutors and politicians
decriminalized all of this stuff
could it look i don't know i'm no
forensic investigator but it would seem
to me that when you have a bunch of
prosecutors and politicians go in and
say we're not going to prosecute these
crimes
and if you were arrested for these
crimes we're going to let you go
that hm maybe you're going to get more
of those crimes
i don't know what do i know i'm no
expert i don't have a degree in this
stuff
michael rappaport voted for this stuff
new york voted for this stuff
it's very sad i love new york
it's it's my home state spent a lot of
time there since i was a kid
and there is there actually is a kind of
base level conservatism to new yorkers a
lot of people outside of new york don't
understand this
it's the kind of trumpy conservatism
the idea that i'm not going to take any
bs from anybody the idea that i'm going
to get in your face a little bit
the idea that i you know it's the
the political scene in new york it's not
like berkeley california it's not not
like san francisco it's not hippie dippy
stuff but they still vote
for democrats and then they have to deal
with the results of these policies
you don't need some big thick
thesis on political philosophy to
understand let the criminals out going
to get more crime okay
and i think there are a lot of people
who are i don't know about michael
rappaport he's still probably a big dem
but
there are a lot of people who are in the
middle who are independents who are soft
liberals who are going to look at this
and say you know
i don't think so no more they are they
tried to do this in this mayoral
election the guy who ran as a democrat
eric adams but he ran on a very pro-cop
kind of message
and so he was he was positioning himself
as the moderate democrat he's not
governing as a moderate democrats it's
probably not going to work
but that that i think that was part of
the phenomenon and you saw it obviously
in the 90s with giuliani even a very
very
left-wing city like new york elects this
republican who's specifically tough on
crime
most successful mayor in the history of
new york this is not complicated for
republicans
crime
education
and immigration depending on which area
of the country you're running in very
simple run on those three things you're
going to do pretty well
why is this
the the democrats are probably going to
have to try to move in this direction
but they're facing a problem right now
which is that they're
they want to win over this moderates and
the soft liberals who are flocking to
the republicans but if they do that
they'll irritate their base which will
kill them
right now
the new york attorney general
has just appointed
a council who supports the abolish ice
movement
a.g leticia james has announced that
zephyr
teachout what a name zephyr teachout a
left-wing attorney and professor at
fordham school of law
we'll join her team
she has
not only said she wants to abolish ice
she says she wants to prosecute ice
immigration enforcement
the democrats are beholden
to their base
there's there's no they they know these
are not stupid people they know that
this is not playing well in peoria it's
not not even playing all that well in
queens or brooklyn
but they are beholden to their base
and so that they've got to put
themselves on the unpopular side of lots
and lots of issues you see this
specifically play out with education
right now conservatives are running on a
platform of education transparency
curriculum transparency meaning teachers
need to put the lesson plans in the
reading list up on websites so the
parents can see it
and democrats don't want that because
democrats are beholden to the teacher
unions and to the radical left so they
know that the minute you put all these
creepy sexual and racial books on the
website for everyone to see that the
parents are going to be upset and are
going to push back on them
so now democrats are on the
anti-transparency side of the issue not
a good place to be if you're in politics
this is how
you can win
the
secretary of homeland security
alejandro mayorkas has put on a good
show talking to the camera saying
everything's great don't worry donald
trump's doing a great job
behind closed doors
there is a
hidden just recently leaked tape of
mayorkas admitting that education
that education that immigration has
never been worse that it's reached
20 30-year lows in terms of immigration
enforcement and this might be the worst
that we have ever seen in this country
now
the the leaked tape which we have
is is nothing new we all know that that
is the case and we all know that they
know that that is the case
but it's it's refreshing it's delightful
it gives you some schadenfreude to hear
them say it
because it raises the question well okay
if it's this bad why don't you just fix
it they can't fix it because they've got
an intrinsic problem as democrats namely
the base
doesn't want them to fix it but the
majority of voters do you know the
latest episode of adam carolla's comedy
series truth yeller is streaming now
adam is joined by silicon valley and
deadpool actor tj miller tj has some
thoughts about basic health
considerations in a post covid world
check it out
ladies and gentlemen comedian actor and
friend tj miller
oh my gosh hello
sorry i was i was just jogging i was
trying to find my dog
but i double fisted because you know it
evens out as you jog the weight this guy
looked at me and he goes it's true it is
true
now i'm joking but you're serious this
guy really does
do it hi hey thank you for having me
thanks for coming out oh i'm excited
this is just a prop though do you want
this
oh you won't take it huh why coven you
one of those guys huh
won't drink a stranger's beer because
the coven
it's terrible what dr fatchi's done to
us head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code miller for 25 off
your membership and look out for the new
episode with tj miller right now it has
never been easier to listen to all of
our content on the go why
because we've just launched listen this
means that you will now be able to
listen to all your favorite daily wire
content on the website and the dw app
whether it's catching morning wire with
a cup of coffee whether it's listening
to your favorite host or exploring our
growing radio theater you will get all
the content you love and if you get
interrupted no worries you can pick up
right where you left off with continue
listening and that's not all we've made
sure it's available to members and
non-members so get ready to listen
because we have got a lot to say we'll
be right back with a lot more
a good rule in politics is to assume
that everything that you say to a group
of people
certainly everything you say if there
are any journalists in the room but even
your own staff anything you write in a
text message or
an email could appear
on the cover of the newspapers you
should just assume that majorcas the
secretary of homeland security did not
assume that and so he was caught on tape
admitting that immigration is worse now
than
possibly ever
we should have enough personnel to take
care of the southern border
and i mean that's that's the solution
and that hasn't been the case look it's
worse
now than it frankly has been in at least
20 years if not ever but that is not
that is absolutely not the solution and
that's a hardship that you're enduring
in service of mission
it's hard it's really hard now why is it
work is it is it worse perhaps because
joe biden said surge come on over khmer
is it worse because the biden
administration is secretly flying
illegal aliens into remote parts of the
country into smaller airports so the
media don't even notice is it worse
because the biden administration is
encouraging this kind of stuff
maybe
that's how that's generally how
incentives work when you incentivize
something you get more of it so why is
he doing it is he a masochist no it's
because it's what his base wants
and it's because he believes it will
give democrats a long-term electoral
advantage because
illegal aliens and specifically one they
can very often vote illegally but two
certainly their children who receive
birthright citizenship or their
grandchildren or their
great-grandchildren are still
overwhelmingly likely to vote for
democrats even several generations down
the road
so this is a long-term play by democrats
problem is
moderates independents soft liberals
hate this stuff and so you're seeing
them flock over
to
the republicans so you've got these
three great issues that republicans can
run on immigration education and crime
there's one other issue
that really shows you the gap between
the democrat base and
every single other demographic in the
country and that is
the media
the establishment
legacy corporate
press
rasmussen just took a poll do you agree
or disagree with this statement the
media are truly the enemy of the people
i assume for most people listening to
this show you would say well that's a
no-brainer that's easy
here's the breakdown by demographic
white people
56 agree the media are truly the enemy
of the people so white people it's only
you know
56 say 44 so it's
not evenly split but relatively close
black people
63
say the media are the enemy of the
people
other non-white people
60 say the media are truly the enemy of
the people so non-white people are more
likely to hate the media and think that
the media are opposed to the people than
white people are and still the majority
of white people think that too
unaffiliated voters 61 say the media are
the enemy of the people gop
says 76 or 76 say the media or the enemy
of the people
among all voters 58
so clear majority of all voters hate the
media
the only group that does not agree with
that statement
democrats 37 percent
so you see the problem here for
democrats the problem is
that black people
hispanic people i guess maybe some
asians included as well non-white
generally
even white people though in a weaker way
all of those groups
and independents and the unaffiliated
they agree with the republicans much
more than they agree with the democrats
on this issue on the issue of the media
they also agree with the republicans
much more than democrats maybe not every
single group but still on on the whole
they agree with republicans over
democrats on crime on education on
immigration
so you've got three regular political
issues just the you know the sort of
stump issues that political candidates
talk about and then you've got this one
meta political issue the media
like the politics of politics
there are political issues the policies
that govern our country then there are
the medical issues the meta political
issues which are the policies that
govern politics how the media are run
how the elections are run how we count
the votes
and on both levels you're seeing a
breaking of pretty much every
demographic for the republicans
so why
why won't democrats change course
because they're beholden to their base
their base has helped them before the
base doesn't appear to be sufficient now
the left is overestimating the amount of
influence and clout that they have
politically and culturally
you saw this in the case of neil young
neil young came out
neil young
a
very well-known musician decades ago
neil young
a very
whiny
hippy
from canada
neil young said it's rogan or me
i don't lie neil young who who with
crosby stills and nash went on the free
speech tour in 2006
told spotify that if they don't censor
joe rogan for having medical experts on
his show who disagree with the
prevailing narrative and dr fauci that
he will pull his music from spotify
and spotify said uh okay neil don't let
the door hit you on the way out and i
said what what are you talking didn't
you hear what i said
hey hey my my
i don't want to say goodbye and they
said see ya see you buddy bye-bye neil
but i have six million listeners a month
right joe rogan has 200 million
listeners a month so bye-bye
and i think he was shocked
by the way i don't even think it was
neil young's call to make
because i i don't think neil young owns
the rights to that to that music right i
assume those songs are owned by some
larger music corporation by a larger
catalog so it created a sticky situation
and he said i'm gonna pull and and
spotify said okay get all your music off
see ya
10 15 years ago that couldn't have
happened
10 15 years ago joe rogan couldn't have
happened
you would have had in those days this
would have been
2010 going to the early 20 teens you had
really just the beginning of the new
media twitter was relatively new
the podcasting was relatively new
you had some people pioneering it like
adam corolla actually
but still the establishment media
meaning the news media meaning the
entertainment media like neil young
meaning hollywood
that that still had a big lock on things
now not so much
and so
spotify stands with joe rogan wonderful
wonderful stuff
we're trying to figure out who's got the
influence where the influence is where
the threats really lie they want to shut
up joe rogan because he's cracked up
much of the leftist influence over the
country
and they want to tamp it down and it's
not working speaking of influence
president trump
has just weighed in
on a congressional race very close to
home
in my new home of nashville
the tennessee 5th congressional district
he has endorsed morgan ortegas who's a
friend of mine she worked at the state
department
lovely lady
she's a recent arrival in nashville
she's running against robbie starbuck
another friend of mine
robbie starbuck also another recent
arrival in nashville
they are both running against several
other candidates who are from nashville
who have spent a lot of time here
one of them is beth harwell she was the
speaker of the tennessee house of
representatives doesn't have nearly as
much national name recognition not as
much media presence but much more
local probably name recognition much
more experience in the district
so you're going to see regardless of any
of these there are other candidates as
well but regardless of
i generally don't endorse in primaries
that's i don't think that's my role
uh
but what you're gonna see play out here
is a real question of where does the
influence lie when you're looking at
candidates like morgan and robbie versus
candidates like say beth and the other
locals you're going to see the question
where is the influence is all politics
still local like tip o'neill used to say
or is all politics national now has that
shifted
are we not really as attached to our
local congressional districts or
counties or towns are we more attached
to the national political party
whoever comes out on top that that might
tell you something
and then the big question is
what's trump's influence
what is trump's influence here
trump is making some big bets he's
endorsing in primaries
most likely
for a lot of seats around the country
and all but one in tennessee they're
gonna break republican in the general
election so that's not the issue the
question is who wins the primaries
there some people were upset with trump
some people wanted trump to endorse
robbie starbuck some people
are upset that he endorsed morrigan
they're all these
little factions of the gop fighting now
for the influence over trump but the
bigger question is does trump have
influence in the districts
if trump's nominees
win the primaries frankly regardless of
whether or not they win the general
that's going to tell you a lot about
trump's standing in 2024. if he is still
the king maker in 2022 he's going to go
into the 2024 race with a lot of
momentum if trump's endorsements do not
matter in 2022 if he endorses primary
candidates and then their opponents win
the primaries
trump is going to go into 24 looking
pretty weak
i think in that case you're going to see
much more of an opening for the other
candidates who were on that list
mike pence ted cruz
ron desantis people who weren't even on
that list
big stakes trump is taking a risk here
but he's got to do it because he's got
to shore up his support looking into
2024.
what is his clout
who is going to win speaking of winning
really excellent news
out of the occupational safety and
health administration
it's a sentence i didn't think i would
say ever
really great news out of osha they have
withdrawn the vaccine mandate for
private employers
now hold on
you might be saying
michael i thought the supreme court
struck down the osha mandate
yes and no
the supreme court
sent the
suspended the osha mandate
while litigation went through and all of
these cases were heard in the lower
courts and the supreme court said that
very likely the people who are going up
against the osha mandate are going to
win on the merits especially if it gets
back up to us the supreme court hint
wink wink we're going to give them the
victory
but the ocean mandate still remained in
place it was just suspended
osha has now voluntarily
somewhat voluntarily withdrawn the
vaccine mandate yesterday
because they knew that they were going
to lose if it went back up to the
supreme court a lot of companies before
osha did that were suspending their own
private mandates but they didn't have to
this is this is a really important
lesson for conservatives who are
enamored of the idea that politics is
downstream of culture or even the
converse of it that
actually
culture is downstream of politics and
that this is always the case you only
work through the government or you only
work through private enterprise actually
it's both what happened in the osha case
is that a private company the daily wire
and some other companies got together
and sued the government
then
the government
stopped the mandate
then
a private company
changed their private policies even
though they didn't have to starbucks
changed for instance there were other
companies too changed their private
policies even though there's nothing in
the court dot order saying that the
private company had to change its
mandate
then the government yet again the osha
agency withdrew
their mandate
i'm dizzy i'm dizzy with all of this
winning how did that happen well it's
because culture influenced politics
politics influenced culture culture
influenced politics again and it was
back and forth and it's really hard to
separate those two things and the left
doesn't separate those two things the
left works in the private sphere and the
left works in the government and the
left wheels the private institutions and
the left wields the government and some
institutions it's kind of hard to tell
the difference is google private kind of
is google the government yeah there's a
lot of government in google
we need to do that too
we need to do that too
the conservatives who say we've got to
focus only on
the culture and private enterprise and
we can never wield the government
they're insane they've got their head in
the sand they're squishes don't listen
to that that's a bad idea and the
conservatives who say forget about
private industry let's just wield the
government like a
cudgel and i actually don't think there
are many conservatives even saying that
but if if there were that they would
they would be missing something too you
need to do both
politics culture society it's just kind
of what we're all doing together man and
we need to wield what leverage what
influence we have to affect our
political vision
our neighbors to the north living in
america's hat are not so lucky
the poor canadians as america is getting
marginally freer by the day you get this
win at the supreme court you get this
win from osha you get this win from
private enterprise
in canada people are locking down even
more it is now illegal
throughout much of canada to go into a
store
to buy things
if you have not received the fouchy
ouchie
they're even making it difficult to go
buy groceries so forget about going in
to buy a gucci handbag
if you go in to buy
chicken and bread to feed your family if
you're going to get drugs at the
pharmacy and you are unvaccinated for
now in canada you are still allowed to
do that you won't be made to starve to
death you won't be made to die without
your medicine
but but if you do that you are going to
have a guard with you at all times to
make sure that you don't buy anything
else
today big box stores that have a
footprint of 1500 square meters or more
are going to have to ask people
customers to show proof of vaccination
now pharmacies and grocery will be
exempt from this so if you're going into
a costco or a walmart or something like
that where you might be going in to buy
groceries or visit the pharmacy in that
case an employee will have to be with
that person as they walk through the
store to make sure that they do not go
and buy other products or other items
that might be in the store
put that down
put down can i buy the twinkie well it's
a margin call it's not necessary for
your nutrition but it is still maybe you
can buy the twinkie but don't buy those
flowers
you're not allowed to have flowers
flowers are for vaccinated people only
no mommy can i have a candy bar
um
i guess it's technically food
mommy can i have that balloon no
no balloons balloons are for vaccinated
customers only
purely
vindictive purely wrathful
these people are already in the store
they're already it's not they're not
going to spread covid more because they
buy a bouquet of flowers
rather than just buying food are they
allowed to buy alcohol
i don't know
i don't know i suspect they don't know
either
we think this sort of thing could never
happen in the civilized world it is
happening in the civilized world canada
australia parts of europe
it could happen here
we're not that far off from this sort of
thing happening in the united states
certainly not in the left-wing cities
what has prevented it
is not even the
charity of our ruling class certainly
not that it's not
the good intentions of the people
it's the structures of power in the
country that even as they've been so
toppled in recent decades
still
can separate power and influence to some
degree
the states still have some power
vis-a-vis the federal government private
industry still has some power vis-a-vis
the bureaucratic agencies for instance
you can still do it for now
very important to hold on to that
leverage and wield it
speaking of the culture shocking new
docu-series
coming out of a e
about hugh hefner
the playboy you know the man who lived
a totally hedonistic existence for his
entire life
had a harem of women
whom he regularly
slept with all of them at the same time
many many times per week turns out this
is pretty shocking
he was kind of a bad guy
did you stop the presses extra extra
read all about it it turns out that hugh
hefner who was lauded by the culture for
many decades
half
turns out he was kind of a bad guy
in this docu-series they
lift the lid on the dark underbelly of
playboy
turns out if you just live with a bunch
of prostitutes for many decades and do a
bunch of drugs and abuse everybody and
just pursue your own pleasure
that might be kind of dark there might
be an it's not an underbell it's an
overbelly every anyone with two brain
cells to rub together knew this except
that playboy
and the popular culture generally
presented this very nice funny
cartoonish image of playboy the reality
was not quite like that one of the
playboy ladies who ran one of the
divisions
said it was cult-like the women had been
groomed and led to believe they were
part of this family heff really did
believe he owned these women we had
playmates that overdosed that committed
suicide
a many documentary participants said
that hefner's insatiable appetites led
to desensitization which led him to
demand stranger and stranger sexual
activities
this led him to watch snuff films films
in which people were being killed and
allegedly uh forcing others to engage in
sex acts with animals or doing so
himself one former playmate said
he scared me in the end you couldn't
satisfy him he wanted more and more and
more
some people are saying well it's really
convenient that now now that hef is dead
all these women are saying this stuff
they were happy to take paychecks for
many years they were happy to live this
lifestyle for many years
but now that he's dead they're coming
after him i don't believe any of it no
look obviously the women made terrible
decisions
but that doesn't let hefner off the hook
of course he did this creepy stuff
he didn't even really hide it did he
the culture just decided to
[Music]
laugh about it the culture just decided
to admire it
the reason i mention the story is not to
stomp on the grave of hugh hefner
who is i'm sure looking up at this uh at
this show right now in dismay
you hope he's not you hope he had some
kind of repentance but he didn't really
show it
did he what these playmates are
describing is that things just got worse
and worse and worse and this is an
important lesson
for
conservatives as we look at the cult how
do you make a better culture we have a
pretty crappy culture right now how do
you make a better culture
you can't have a better culture
without
having people do better things and you
can't have people do better things
namely vice instead of virtue without
having inducements and incentives to
those better things and some of those
might be through private enterprise and
some of those might be through the
government and some is culture and some
is politics but as we've been describing
the two are kind of hard to separate
it's kind of hard to see the difference
sometimes between public and private
particularly since in recent years the
form of government we have is has used
is called the euphemistic public-private
partnership that's what you hear a lot
of liberals we need public-private
partnerships mussolini had public
private partnerships
we have an idea here that we that when
you engage in some vice
and you engage in sin
and you live a hedonistic lifestyle for
a little bit it just blows off steam
that'll actually make society more
stable if you permit lots of vice and
sin and terrible stuff that's going to
make society more stable because people
aren't going to be so repressed
that's not how it works
virtue and vice actually are habits
the more vice you commit
the more vicious it's going to get
the more virtue you practice the more
virtuous you are going to get
you're never going to be perfect
you're probably not going to be totally
depraved and destroyed and hideous
you're gonna be totally evil and you're
not gonna be totally wonderfully perfect
and holy probably
but the more you practice one the more
you're gonna get the more you practice
the other the more you're gonna get
that's true on the individual level and
it's true for society i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show